Elon is playing 3D chess he really is
Trump isn't and Trump's a great guy but
elon's smarter and when it really comes
to full spectrum stuff Elon knows they
charged up this giant battery of
hundreds of thousands of syndicated
articles because you know one gets out a
thousand times or more I mean we're
talking thousands of original articles
thousands of original shows I mean I've
been on PBS that I know of like 50 times
just I mean just program program just
just everything just every channel pmpr
every day so Elon knows I'm this charged
up bomb with this big hand grenade so he
can free the captives it already took
half his advertising he's barely hanging
on they're coming in with him with the
esgs as you said last night he may not
win this if he brings me on they can go
look he brought Satan on so he can free
everybody but me the Taliban everybody
else that's fine I kind of and I
understand it and I'm not I'm being
honest here now that I'm more
sophisticated I understand that